we work hard
garages is destroying everything that's
destroying the country as a whole people
have lost hope because they just don't
feel like they really change I'm very
upset about it I want to remind them
that it's either we do something about
it or just leave it to get worse than it
already is
I think things like is the best way to
do it it's a powerful tool
have a seat have a seat have a cinnamon
have a silly have a cinnamon how I spoke
to her IVA see them what happened yeah
what happens actually hi bacilli is
basically a track that is just focusing
on corruption yeah corruption that is
going on in our country that is going on
in the government every everywhere you
go corruption every way from our police
forces to people that we actually look
up to you know what I mean
so it's a sister track that is just
sending out a message or an entre so I
write and it has to stop I teamed up
with a corruption watch essay so it's a
campaign it's a movement pocket mm-hmm
I'm the director for Fiesta blacks hi
vasila music video we are coming from
you and Aspen Hills Johannesburg South
we're taking this entire club filled the
most opulent arrogant people in the
whole world and turn it upside down
listen every party let's get your first
positions and start shooting now and
action
my
blue
corruption destroys the trust that we
have in our public institutions the
people who suffer the most those that
are marginalized and that love in poor
in poor ears and they're loving below
the prayer line because they are
depending on the government for services
which are not being provided and they
still this major gap between the very
rich in the way before and I do believe
that corruption is a major cause of this
divide between our society what would
you like to tell the youth of South
Africa you know I just want people to
join me on this fight because obviously
I can't do it alone I can't be the only
one willing to fight I wanted to say
I've got a big mouth I talk a lot so I
was like this is a time for me to just
talk talk talk and say everything that I
want to say
yeah we in the hood now hey now we are
now in the slums like deep yeah we can
clip down
just look around you
okay look at everything
why not you have like 20 people living
in one yard which is like all these
shacks and everything so I'm just going
to talk to them about it and figure out
what they think should be happening what
should be given to them what they feel
as much you know being delivered and how
they feel about everything education and
because yen Krypton there's too many
there's a lot of chopping school
pregnancy and it's often when the wind
blows these things goes like oh my god
sleepy it's so cold this is a politic
area you know this is my freedom Charter
was fine just he's here
no the student Charter was signed and I
think yeah it uh it is Church but this
is the place government was supposed to
look at first because everybody got to
them because of their company
okay and here's my granny okay go
no no he said she's strong
my grandmother is 97 and she you see how
she's standing she's drunk and she can
run if you mix with her she'll hit you
with the stick
never my mother children happen to need
Olivia coke oh you know I'm calling a
woman went woodsy eternity but yeah it
takes no ice in any cell phone face on
each each a free micaiah Bhaiji paying
boom
Grabavoy can tele 120 levering care a
type 100 runs ever we ever stay off a
kick helpfully touch a litera Baku's
Veronica or Abajo Nova Wow then FA
interrupted a because when la Kowalik
it's a Mayan vowel Valley are nervous to
move around
uma Gracie
it's a very good example of corruption
academic identity the corruption
watching them licky corruption at its
peak one and it's not only my mama alone
you must do something about it hmm we
must do something about it not like free
time well I'm gonna talked about
corruption Raj we're gonna do something
about it goes bad there's a there's so
many old people here whoever's doing
that is making so much money every man
from cooking the elderly out of their
pension money people are receiving it
very well they love the name of the song
hi Vasily they work if it's catchy and
they agreed they wicked people actually
do care and they do want to change
Mandela has passed on the world has come
to South Africa
what is work all is not work